are they gonna do with five bedrooms you
guys are obviously never having kids
what was that look I did not do a look
you're doing a look right man
there's no have a good fight guys
there's so many kids in foster care
I found this adoption really [ __ ] they
don't know me they break my heart I just
got home from work we found a great
match for you guys
most folks want nothing to do with
teenagers they use drugs and they watch
people playing video games on YouTube i
FY i we can all hear you hmm
it's okay let me go with the kitties and
don't give it another thought bye bye
she was cool she comes with two younger
siblings one and you two three kids too
much
finally to show us that what are we
supposed to say no to that now make
yourself at home I'm not saying we're
perfect parents should we give them a
kiss good but we might have a little bit
of a knack for this
are you sure keep in mind folks it is
not gonna be easy mom Annie that's a
marker that's gonna do I'll wait here
these kids will test your will I plated
a hundred and fifty games of Candyland
with Lena you ever play freakin Camille
and it's Rudolph's very dull and push
button you didn't even know your hand we
could have just picked a toddler who
doesn't have the pinions and Thal
underwear what are you wearing
sorry you know dressed like an upstate
douche like you hey this is real
cashmere dress like a dude no but with
some structure and love these kids could
blossom only things to see everything's
gonna be okay
taking naked selfies of herself
honey what exactly is a dick pic Jesus
that is a trout picture you send her
Jacob you're lucky I'll end your life
right now
carrot top I'm gonna call your mom
you're going down - danga what do you
think of that shake him my name is on
Jacob
what okay okay okay
[Music]
you